i do want to talk a little bit about
maybe since you did work with tasso
what you think your opinion
of what his psychology is
do you think because i've been trying to
figure this out do you think that this
was a grand strategy from the beginning
to screw everybody
out of equity or do you think over time
he realized well it's been architected
that i have the llc i have
control all of these discussions have
been verbal
nothing's been put in writing therefore
worst case scenario people have to sue
me and i settle
best case scenario i demoralize
everybody
and they give up and if you know let's
say
he would have owned 50 of the company he
gets to own a hundred
because this seems to me such a
deliberate
breaking of the covenant right of the
agreement
the sacred agreement here in silicon
valley both from
rank and file employees like yourself
frontline employees
co-founders and investors that this
seems to me to be a pre-meditated
screwing of
everybody up and down the stack what do
you think having worked with him
for almost eight years um i just
i disagree you know um i i think that
this was something that
that would that grew i don't think that
it was his plan originally
i don't think when he talked to me and
promised me what he did you know back
then
well he didn't even he didn't say shares
he didn't say you know he said 10 000 in
equity
i i you know back then i had no idea
what that meant in my mind i'm thinking
well
you know if uh dude it's the fan at
least i got ten thousand dollars you
know
yeah you know i didn't really think
about the whole increase in valuation or
anything like that
or what it would even mean you know 10
000 back then is worth what
now blah blah blah so 20 times 30 times
40 times
yeah yeah yeah yeah no we're not going
there man
no i mean when you joined and he made
that offer to you in the first or second
year oh yeah
oh yeah and at that time how many
employees were there
uh we had six or seven i think yeah all
right so you were there in the first
year the company was worth in that first
year 10 million i was number
i was number three or four depending on
how you look at it alvaro and i both
started on
uh uh february or no march 1st 2011
so we were both three and four yeah
scott let me explain to you what you
should have gotten
and i'm not doing this to rub salt in it
but i'm doing it because i think it's
important
and you've been kind enough to come on
here that uh employees protect
themselves
that's the good that can come out of
this but as the third or fourth employee
um and given ten thousand
ten that a hundred thousand would be one
percent of the company ten basis points
would be
ten thousand right so that would be the
valuation at that early stage some would
argue half of that
the company would have been diluted
maybe 20 at this time right if they had
actually converted that 1.5 million
around or converted 15 right diluted 15
in other words
they would have added some there so what
that would equal to
you the company now is doing 200 million
i heard or something like that is that
the public whisper number
yeah um now keep in mind according to
toso
that's uh they're trying to compare
apple's oranges with with um
wework which used to be odessa no no
excuse me
pardon me uh oh desk uh which is uh
upwork thank you there we go yeah upwork
as uh well they're looking at the gross
numbers which
a lot of that does go to the um to the
developer right but they take 30
is that right something in that range it
it it varies but yeah
it's in that range usually okay so 30 of
200 million 60 million 60 million
um you know you would base the company
on at least 20 times that so it'd be 1.2
billion
1.2 billion if you owned
one percent of that would be 10 million
and 10 basis points would be 1.2 million
you are entitled to 1.2 million in my
estimation right now
that's what you should have gotten and
also in the first three or four
employees you would get a premium for
being the person who took the most
risk so at ten thousand dollars it'd be
you know 10 to 20 basis points would be
1.2 to 2.4 million
dollars worst case best case you
probably should have gotten just a
straight up point
as an early employee like this one point
would have been 10 million